The essence of being human
is that we solve problems.
And when we're faced
with enormous problems
like disease and climate change,
we need to solve them by collaboration.
I'm excited to tell you
about a new kind of collaboration
that will absolutely create solutions
to these big problems.
It's a collaboration that's unexpected
because it's between humans
and the tiniest organisms
that populate our planet:
the bacteria and other microbes
that live in, on and around us.
Bacteria may be small and unseen,
but they often have inspired
transformative innovations,
including the one that has become
the cornerstone of my own research.
Over the past decade,
I've been at the forefront
of developing a revolutionary
technology called CRISPR
that has come from the study
of how bacteria fight viral infection.
CRISPR is amazing because it allows us
to precisely edit the DNA
in living organisms,
including in people and plants.
With CRISPR, we can change,
remove or replace the genes
that govern the function of cells.
This means that we now have the ability
to use CRISPR like a word processor
to find, cut and paste text.
CRISPR, amazingly, has already
cured people of devastating disorders
like sickle cell disease,
and it's created rice plants
that are resistant
to both diseases and drought.
Incredible, right?
But the next world-changing
advance with CRISPR
will actually come from using it in a way
that will allow us to go to the next level
by editing genes beyond
just in individual organisms.
We now have the ability to use CRISPR
to edit entire populations
of tiny microbes,
called microbiomes,
that live in and on our bodies.
For decades, scientists studied bacteria
one organism at a time,
as if each type of bacteria
behaved independently.
But we now know that bacterial behaviors,
both good and bad,
result from their interactions
within complex microbiomes.
In humans, dysfunctional gut microbiomes
are associated with diseases as diverse
as Alzheimer's and asthma.
And in farm animals,
microbiomes produce methane,
a powerful contributor to climate change.
But when they're healthy,
both human and animal microbiomes
can actually prevent disease
and reduce methane emissions.
So to harness these benefits,
we need a way to precisely
and reproducibly control
these microbial communities.
So why have microbiomes been difficult
to control in the past?
It turns out that microbiomes
are very complex,
and they're difficult to manipulate.
Antibiotics affect the entire microbiome
and their overuse
can lead to drug resistance.
Diet and probiotics are nonspecific
and they're often ineffective.
Fecal transplants face various challenges
to both effectiveness and acceptance.
(Laughter)
But with CRISPR, we have a tool
that works like a scalpel.
It allows us to target a particular gene
in a particular kind of cell.
With CRISPR, we can change
one kind of bacterium
without affecting all the others.
Another challenge is that less than one
percent of the world’s microbial species
have been grown and studied in the lab.
Fortunately, we can now
access the other 99 percent
due to the pioneering research
of my colleague, Jill Banfield,
and her breakthrough technology,
metagenomics,
which is a tool
that allows us to figure out
what species are present
and what they're doing
in a microbial community.
Metagenomics creates a detailed blueprint
of a complex microbiome,
and that means that we can use it
to figure out how to use
gene editing tools
in the right gene, in the right organism.
You might be wondering
how we can take this new knowledge
and harness it to solve
real world problems.
Well, we're bringing together
these two breakthrough technologies,
metagenomics and CRISPR,
to create a brand new field of science
called precision microbiome editing.
This will allow us to discover links
between dysfunctional microbiomes
and disease or greenhouse gas emissions.
We can develop modified
and improved microbiome editors
and show that they're safe and effective.
And we can then begin to deploy
these optimized solutions
to create the kinds of solutions
that will be transformative in the future.
So how does this affect our health
and the health of our planet?
We know the poorest countries and people
are the most affected by climate change,
and it's a problem created
by the wealthiest people.
And methane is a big part of the problem.
It's been a major contributor
to rising global temperatures
since preindustrial times.
Specific microbiome
compositions in livestock
can actually reduce
methane emissions by up to 80 percent.
But doing that today currently requires
daily interventions at enormous expense,
and it just doesn't scale.
But with precision microbiome editing,
we have an opportunity
to modify a calf's microbiome at birth,
limiting that animal's impact
on the climate for its entire lifetime.
And this is beneficial for farmers
because reduced methane production
means more efficient conversion
of feed into food.
Importantly, these tools
can be used in the future
to reduce methane emissions
from other sources,
like landfills, wastewater
and rice paddies.
Ultimately, microbiomes generate
up to two-thirds of all of the methane
emissions globally.
So our technology
could really move the needle
in our fight against climate change.
In human health,
asthma affects up to 300 million
people around the world,
a number that grows
by 50 percent each decade,
and it disproportionately affects
lower-income children.
Our team has identified a promising link
between a molecule
produced in the gut microbiome
and asthma development.
With precision microbiome editing,
we could offer a child at risk for asthma
a noninvasive therapy
that would eliminate
asthma-inducing molecules,
changing her life trajectory.
And what's really exciting
is that these same approaches
in the future could help us treat
or even prevent human diseases
that are linked to the gut microbiome,
including obesity,
diabetes and Alzheimer's.
I think it’s fascinating
that we can now use CRISPR
to edit the same tiny organisms
that gave us CRISPR.
In doing so, we’re collaborating
with the ultimate partner: nature.
Together, we can use CRISPR-powered
precision microbiome editing
to build a more resilient
future for all of us.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)